foreign
is a company that basically automates
other companies security and compliance
processes so the security part is like
making sure a company is managing and
storing customer data in a way that's
like safe
[Music]
so a lot of the stock
s has all this cost
s and we sort of found that when you
know that there's a data breach or
there's a security hack right now data
is everywhere it has like real
consequences for people I feel like
Equifax or Target or these big breaches
and so there's just so much scrutiny on
whether companies are kind of doing the
right thing and securing the customer
data they have
um and they're right there's kind of
rightly a lot of scrutiny on that the
notable thing about vanta's investment
strategy was Christina the founder and
CEO like worked in Venture as her first
like institutional job out of college
basically and from that there are two I
guess lessons that she likes to talk
about one is that companies are the best
at like raising money when they don't
need it and the other is that it's like
easy to confuse fundraising success with
like company product success and I think
she's been really conscious about trying
like not to fall into those traps
Christina actually waited until Vantage
reached 10 million in annual recurring
Revenue which is like the way Phantom
measures Revenue because it's a
subscription-based company to raise its
first like big institutional funding
round at series a most companies usually
try to raise a series a when it's like 1
million at that metric so vanta waited
until much later so that was in May of
2021 they raised 50 million in a series
a led by Sequoia and then a year later
they announced the series B in June of
2022 it was at 110 million round LED by
Craft Ventures and that round valued the
company at 1.6 billion dollars
so when vanta launched in 2018 we
launched this category of automated
compliance so helping companies get
compliant and secure quickly since then
we've grown with our customers and now
offer a broader trust management
platform but still stay in core to
helping technology companies secure the
customer data they have and then go
demonstrate and prove that they're you
know have reasonable security to their
customers so they can go grow their
business Tony was a product manager at
Dropbox trying to take a new product to
Market and we were really excited about
giving the product to you know big
companies Enterprise customers and and
then you know the legal team kind of
correctly told us we we couldn't do that
we couldn't show that the product was
Secure and compliant you know we thought
we had reasonable practices but we
couldn't demonstrate them in the way
these Enterprise is expected and I
didn't know anything about the space But
as more and more I learned the process
itself or the the goal made sense right
it's like of course we should show we're
trustworthy to Big customers and do the
right thing with that scrutiny ends up
meaning is these companies have to one
have reasonable practices and two then
go through these pretty onerous
processes to prove they have good
security practices right and they're
actually securing the data and
historically that was like like
spreadsheets and manual Audits and like
everything was one off which will Took a
ton of time and effort and also it's
like pretty inefficient because we're
like talking about software and we're
taking it into you know pieces of paper
almost literally
but companies would still go through it
because it was so important to them to
show that they were good and stewards of
customer data and their customers wanted
that you know almost before they'd make
the purchase right so it's like such an
important thing to prove and felt you
know kind of a like a large problem and
an important one to solve because as
someone who who builds software
um I actually do believe I still believe
in the transformative power of software
but you know we can't do that if we
don't trust it
I think in the beginning you know
because we created the category because
we created the product we didn't have
software competition we truly were the
only thing and so the the trick and the
the kind of sales or go to market
processes was convincing someone they
could rely on software for something
they had a bunch of manual processes
before as like kind of 2020 and 2021
went on and just more startups got
funded there were more entrants into the
space people copied what we did took it
to Market and I think that you know
breeds some amount of resilience it it
deeply shows that in software you're
sort of only as good as your your last
release in a lot of ways and you may
have created the category and brought
this new product to Market and done this
Innovation but if that happened two
years ago right it's it's much more
about well what's you know what are you
doing this quarter next quarter how are
you continuing to show that you're
useful to customers and not sort of
resting on The Laurels of my prior
success I think weeding to reading until
we were 10 million in error are to raise
our series a instilled a lot of
discipline in the company it forced us
to think about are we doing the right
thing do we have a good business not
um does some VC think we have a good
business right it kind of made it more
insular in a helpful way there I also
think it forced some discipline around
practices like we charge customers
annually up front and it's like cash
flow things that actually helped us not
need funding for longer and in those
ways it you know those sort of smaller
decisions helped us build a stronger
more resilient business
um and I think finally afterwards like
we didn't need the cash and again some
of it was things like charging annually
up front but
um we you know we certainly had problems
to solve but they weren't problems where
it felt like it was you know more money
would solve them felt like more money
actually might make it more complicated
or raise the stakes or do other things
and so you know why don't we solve those
problems first and then when we get to
the problems where it seems like money
can solve them
you know go go pursue investment
few things came across really clearly
when I was talking to Christina and like
her former and current business partners
and investors
um one is that she's like super Scrappy
and really prioritizes like product over
ego like when I was asking her oh like
was Fanta the category Creator she was
like well visibly uncomfortable like I
don't want to like claim credit for this
kind of thing
um and that's definitely something that
carries into like how she runs a
business the other thing is that she's
like clearly someone who like will learn
anything for the sake of learning it
so prior to vanta I worked at an early
stage investment firm like VC firm in
New York Union Square Ventures I think
working at the early stage VC firm and
interacting with like seed stage
Founders I very much wanted to be one of
them and start a company I didn't quite
know in what yet I got into beanie
babies when I was like in fourth grade
because my my mom's family lived in
Chicago and they found out about them a
little earlier than everyone else and
um collected Beanie Babies had still
have hundreds of them in my mom's
basement much to her Chagrin and then
um got to like buying and selling them
on eBay like early eBay
um and
putting them together in different like
groupings and trying to sell them that
way and riding my bike to Kroger just
like the local grocery store to get
money orders because this was
before there were many credit cards in
the internet and I definitely didn't
have a credit card at this stage
um so I would like go to Kroger and like
slide quarters across the counter and
get a money order basically to go pay
for them I think one thing from when I
was a kid to now is is kind of a deep
curiosity and I really do like to learn
things for the sake of learning things
sometimes to a fault
um as a college student at meant I
change my major like 12 times I like
couldn't really settle on something
um so there's definitely too much but I
think in this role it's been really
helpful because for the first couple
years of a quickly growing company
you're sort of doing all of the
different roles in a company until you
can sort of do them well enough to
convince someone who is much more
experienced and much better than you to
come in and do it better than you were
and going into each of the those new
roles and being like well you know I
don't I didn't know what customer
success is but I'm gonna go talk to the
people and do the things and and learn
about it and figuring out how to joy in
that versus just feeling like it's
another Hill to climb
um I think I think that Curiosity piece
has been helpful
foreign